nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour
répondre à une question d'une simplicité
extrême et d'une importance majeure à
l'heure où partout dans le monde partout
dans le monde les forces réactionnaires
progressent à l'heure où les droits des
femmes les droits reproductifs et
sexuels sont partout attaqués alors ou
en Europe les femmes se préparent à la
contre-offensive à l'heure où la France
peut retrouver un rôle de pionnière de
modèles et d'espérance nous devons
répondre à une question
préférons nous une société où le droit à
l'avortement est protégé au sommet de la
hiérarchie des normes ou une société ou
une simple loi peut le défaire
préférons-nous agir aujourd'hui au
risque au pire que cette garantie ne se
révèle jamais nécessaire ou ne rien
faire au risque de balayer le droit
fondamental des générations futures
voulons-nous répondre positivement à 80%
des Françaises et des Français toutes
catégorie sociale préférence politique
appartenance religieuse confondues qui
demande que le droit l'avortement soit
reconnu dans le texte qui fonde notre
contrat social ou non souhaitons à
toutes les femmes de ce pays que le
Parlement est de leur côté que l'honneur
de la France c'est son idéal d'égalité
c'est de considérer que la maîtrise de
sa fécondité est une affaire de liberté
mais aussi simplement une affaire de
citoyenneté d'égalité des droits et que
pour cette raison nous les régions au
sommet de nos normes souhaitons-nous
montrer à toutes les femmes du monde à
toutes celles et ceux qui se battent si
nombreuses et si nombreux contre le
fascisme contre le totalitarisme
religieux celui des Molay iraniens des
évangélistes texan ou des intégristes
bien français à toutes celles et ceux
qui en Pologne en Hongrie en Italie aux
États-Unis en Iran au Maroc à Malte dans
tant de pays se battent pour avoir le
droit d'être considéré comme des êtres
humains qui disposent de leur corps et
au fond de leur destin et de leur vie
que non tout n'est pas perdu que dans
cette période si sombre il existe dans
ce monde un chemin un chemin de progrès
dans lequel notre pays a fait le choix
de s'engager et dans lequel il invite
les autres nations elle y rejoindre le
droit à l'avortement est un actif
féministe et comme tous les aquifs
féministes il n'est jamais hors de
danger jamais c'est aussi un acquis
profondément républicain parce qu'il
répond à la promesse républicaine et
universaliste d'égalité des droits un
acquis qu'il vous est simplement proposé
aujourd'hui de mieux protéger où trouver
l'envie en 2022 d'argumenter contre une
loi qui ne ferait rien d'autre que des
sanctuariser un droit que prétendument
nous chérissons tout et tous c'est je
vous l'assure pour tellement de
personnes qui nous regardent un profond
mystère je remercie évidemment madame la
rapporteur pour son travail je sais que
cela n'a pas toujours été le travail le
plus facile mais je voudrais revenir sur
les arguments utilisés pour refuser
cette loi
premièrement l'argument classique ça ne
sert à rien d'abord parce que ce droit
n'est pas menacé donc c'est un peu comme
dire je suis dans ma voiture ça sert à
rien que je mette ma ceinture parce que
je ne suis pas en train d'avoir un
accident
cette vie cet argument n'a évidemment
aucun sens parce que par définition on
se protège d'un risque avant qu'il
advienne mais aussi parce qu'on le sait
très bien le jour où il aura un risque
concret en France c'est-à-dire quoi un
nombre conséquent d'élus tenter de
remettre en cause ce droit et bien ce
jour-là une protection constitutionnelle
sera par définition hors de portée
puisque la majorité pour changer la
Constitution est supérieure à celle pour
changer la loi et que c'est précisément
pour ça que nous voulons l'inscrire dans
la Constitution c'est donc exactement
parce qu'il existe aujourd'hui en France
une écrasante majorité dans les urnes
dans la rue dans les institutions pour
le droit à l'avortement que l'on peut et
que l'on doit le protéger maintenant
deuxièmement ça ne sert à rien parce que
c'est pas une protection absolue la
Constitution peut toujours la modifier
donc là c'est je mets pas ma ceinture de
sécurité parce que on sait pas il peut y
avoir un tsunami alors c'est pas faux on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'un putsch d'une
révolution d'un astéroïde qui
percuterait la France donc je suis même
pas tout à fait sûr de savoir au fond
pourquoi on a une constitution des élus
qui se lèvent le matin pour légiférer de
toute façon il y a des gens qui violent
la loi tous les jours et il y a des élus
qui changent la loi en permanence donc
on a quand même d'un côté ça sert à rien
parce qu'il y a pas de risque et de
l'autre ça sert à rien parce que le
risque est trop grand donc c'est un peu
difficile à suivre mais c'est pas fini
troisième argument ça ne sert à rien
parce que c'est déjà protégé par la
Constitution donc en fait je dois pas
mettre ma ceinture parce que je l'ai
déjà il faut surtout pas mettre sa
ceinture parce qu'il y a pas de risque
le risque est trop grand et finalement
mesdames et messieurs parce que
heureusement je l'ai déjà donc c'est
assez épatant et là encore le problème
c'est que c'est faux la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel n'a jamais
dégagé de manière positive un droit à
l'interrupteur à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse jamais elle
s'est contentée d'affirmer que les
différentes lois qui en le droit à l'IVG
ne violez pas la Constitution et les
fins juristes que vous êtes connaissent
très bien la différence si demain et ça
toutes les personnes qui nous écoutent
doivent le savoir si demain il doit
régressive qui viserait à réduire les
délais légaux à des remboursés ajoutez
des conditions pour accéder à
l'avortement à imposer une ordonnance
pour accéder à la pilule du lendemain
venez à être présenté devant le Conseil
constitutionnel ce dernier n'aurait rien
pour statuer sur son
inconstitutionnalité rien et c'est ça
que nous voulons corriger
argument suivant ça ne va rien changer
parce que l'important est ailleurs comme
toujours ce n'est pas le droit c'est
l'accès aux droits alors déjà j'aimerais
vous dire une chose on n'a pas accès à
un droit qui n'existe plus
et puis quel est le rapport cette loi va
non seulement permettre de réclamer un
meilleur accès partout mais surtout elle
ne vous empêchera pas je vous l'assure
jamais bien au contraire de voter pour
l'augmentation des crédits pour les
associations et les centres de soins pas
du tout
argument suivant la Constitution ne doit
pas être un catalogue et n'a pas à
protéger les Français contre des
changements par exemple faire reculer le
droit l'avortement qu'il pourrait
démocratiquement vouloir demain et ben
si parce que dans ce cas là à quoi ça
sert d'avoir une constitution et un bloc
de constitutionnalité à quoi ça sert de
protéger le caractère laïque de la
République notre attachement au
préambule de 46 l'interdiction de la
peine de mort à rien dans ce cas-là le
dernier argument et je j'avoue c'est un
peu mon préféré
il faut pas importer des débats des
États-Unis
comme s'il n'y avait que aux États-Unis
qu'on attaquait le droit à l'IVG en
Italie donc juste à côté une proposition
loi vient naître déposée par la droite
pas par l'extrême droite par la droite
pour restreindre le droit à l'avortement
mais en France on serait nationalement
immunisé puis je trouve que nous avons
d'un côté de cette émission une haine
très sélective des importations de débat
en particulier venant des États-Unis
parce que quand il s'agit d'importer des
débats totalement construits au sujet
d'un prétendu danger causé par un
prétendu concept dont personne ne se
réclame en France et que personne n'est
capable de définir c'est bien mais quand
les débats prétendument apporter à
propos de risque bien réels peuvent
générer des progrès bien réels là c'est
mal alors admettons mettez-moi de côté
mais Laurence Rossignol qui le porte
depuis 2012 Elian assassy Laurence Cohen
qui dès 2017 5 ans avant l'arrêt de la
cour de suprême avait déjà fait cette
proposition Daphné rakmadou Xavier
yakovelli Maryse Carrère jouait de
Gueriot que je remercie une fois encore
ne sont pas importés je suis désolé ils
sont bien ici et ils posent ici au Sénat
français une question bien française la
France a en son cœur des femmes qui
depuis des siècles se battent pour
conquérir leurs droits à elle et par la
même pour protéger les droits tout court
alors je vais vous dire une chose si
vous devez y avoir aujourd'hui une
spécificité française ce ne serait pas
d'être prétendument le seul pays au
monde protégé des recules ce serait au
contraire de devenir le premier pays au
monde à décider d'agir en amont plutôt
que de réagir quand il est trop tard en
tant que coprésidente du Parti vert
européen partageons ma vie avec une
féministe allemande qui se bat depuis
toujours pour quand en Allemagne
l'avortement soit retiré du droit du
code pénal je peux vous dire une chose
vous mesurez très mal très mal
l'importance pour l'Europe entière du
vote d'aujourd'hui la force que cela
donnerait à des millions de défenseurs
et de défenseurs des droits humains
elles ne peuvent être méprisées par le
pays qui se veut celui des droits
universels j'ai passé ces dernières
semaines
des jours et des nuits à chercher
quels arguments marcheraient le mieux
pour convaincre la droite sénatoriale de
voter ce texte au nom de ce que je crois
être le sens profond de notre mandat et
puis je me suis dit qu'en fait
c'était à vous de convaincre de
convaincre les Françaises et les
Français que le droit à l'avortement est
pour vous vraiment un droit fondamental
vous avez la majorité c'est vrai une
victoire aujourd'hui serait la vôtre et
un échec aussi
je voudrais finir en m'adressant à
toutes les personnes mobilisées qui nous
écoutent et qui attendent de nous que
nous les protions je veux vous dire
je ne sais pas si on va y arriver
aujourd'hui
mais je sais qu'on y arrivera un jour et
je sais que ce jour tous ceux qui
s'opposent aujourd'hui à se progrès
l'applaudiront très fort en seront très
fiers tandis qu'ils seront encore très
occupés à en freiner d'autres alors ne
lâchez rien jamais c'est vous par votre
mobilisation qui depuis toujours
écrivait l'histoire et en particulier
l'histoire des combats des droits des
femmes je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Madame Agnès
canailler rapporteur de la commission
des lois pour 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux madame la ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
mes chers collègues le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et la contraception font partie
intégrante de notre patrimoine juridique
fondamental ces acquis ont été obtenus
grâce au courage et à l'engagement de
Simone Veil et de Lucien Nevers qui se
sont battus avec détermination pour les
faire inscrire dans la loi aujourd'hui
ses droits sont pleinement protégés par
le droit positif le Sénat c'est toujours
montré fortement attaché à ces libertés
de la femme depuis la loi du 17 janvier
1975 la liberté d'interrompre sa
grossesse n'a cessé d'être conforté par
cette foi le législateur l'a renforcé
avec encore récemment l'allongement du
délai à 14 semaines quant à la
contraception consacrée par la loi du 28
décembre 1967 son accès n'a cessé d'être
étendu au fil des années la
contraception est délivrée gratuitement
pour les mineurs
depuis cette année elle est pour toutes
les femmes de moins de 26 ans et à
partir de 2023 la contraception
d'urgence sera gratuite pour toutes les
femmes aujourd'hui à ma connaissance
personne dans cet assemblée ne veut
revenir sur ses avancées la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle dont nous avons
à débattre aujourd'hui et partez et
porté par notre collègue mais la niveau
gel est consignée par 118 sénateurs elle
a été introduite en réaction à
l'actualité américaine marquée par le
revirement de la jurisprudence de la
Cour suprême du 24 juin dernier dops
versus Jackson cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle tente à inscrire au
titre 8 de la Constitution un article
66.2 qui affirme nul ne peut porter
atteinte au droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse et à la
contraception la loi garantit à toute
personne qui en fait la demande là c'est
l'accès libre effectif assez droit selon
les auteurs cette inscription Lisa
garantir un accès effectif libre et
traditionnel à l'IVG ainsi qu'à la
contraception et à prévenir de toute
régression si l'on peut comprendre
l'émotion susciter outre-Atlantique par
la jurisprudence de la Cour suprême la
révision constitutionnelle ne peut être
en France une réponse pertinente tout
d'abord il n'y a pas lieu d'importer en
France un débat lié à la culture
américaine et à la nature fédérale des
États-Unis ce débat n'est pas le nôtre
la situation institutionnelle en France
n'étant rien comparable à celle des
États-Unis contrairement à ces derniers
la République française est une et
intrévisible autrement dit les lois
veillent et nevirs qui se sont pas
remises en cause aujourd'hui en France
s'appliquent de manière
identique sur tout le territoire la
question centrale en France reste
l'effectivité de ses droits seuls des
mesures concrètes comme la lutte contre
les déserts médicaux notamment en milieu
rural la valorisation des actes médicaux
des personnels soignants pratiquant
l'IVG l'augmentation des moyens des
plannings familiaux permettront le plan
d'accès à ses droits mais ces mesures
relèvent du domaine réglementaire
l'inscription dans la Constitution n'est
donc pas la réponse adaptée pour
renforcer la garantie de ses droits
inscrits dans notre patrimoine juridique
l'idée j'ai le droit à la contraception
font déjà l'objet d'une protection
constitutionnelle solide et durable
solide car l'IVG est inscrite dans notre
droit depuis 1975 le Conseil
constitutionnel l'a toujours jugé
conforme à Camp de la Constitution et
par quatre fois ces prononcé en faveur
de ce droit en 1975 en 2001 en 2014 en
2016 l'IVG est aujourd'hui une
composante de la liberté de la femme
découlant de l'article 2 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen qui se concilient avec le
principe de sauvegarde de la dignité de
la personne humaine comme contre toute
forme de dégradation plus que solide
cette protection est durable comme le
témoigne la jurisprudence constante du
Conseil constitutionnel qui a toujours
considéré que bien que le législateur
dispose de larges de manœuvre pour
définir les conditions d'exercice d'un
droit ou d'une liberté il ne peut en
remettre en cause son effectivité c'est
le fameux effet artichaut que nous
devons doyeux un favoreux on ne peut
toucher au coeur des droits et des
libertés reconnues d'ailleurs en 2018
Agnès Buzyn et Nicole Belloubet alors
ministre avait affirmé devant le
Parlement l'inutilité d'inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution en
les raisons de l'extrême solidité de sa
protection constitutionnelle quatre
années plus tard la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle dont nous débattons ce
jour comporte toujours des risques
largement supérieurs à la seule porte et
symbolique recherchée par les auteurs
l'inscription dans la Constitution du
droit à l'IVG à la contraception tant à
dénaturer l'esprit de la Constitution et
à ouvrir une boîte de Pandore en effet
la Constitution voulue par le général de
Gaulle est avant tout un tieks qui régit
le fonctionnement de nos institutions
faire un catalogue de droit risque de
porter atteinte au rôle protecteur de la
norme suprême et à minorer la portée de
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel gardien de nos droits et
de nos libertés en 2008 Simone Veil
présidente du comité de réflexion sur le
préambule de la Constitution recommandé
elle-même de ne pas modifier le
préambule ni d'intégrer dans la
constitution des droits et des libertés
liées à la bioéthique qui intégrait
l'IVG elle préconise éclairement le
refus d'inscrire des dispositions de
purement de portée purement symbolique
seuls quatre raisons justifie une
modification de la Constitution pour
introduire un droit nouveau pour déroger
à un principe que la Constitution impose
ce fut le cas en 1999 et en 2008 pour
autoriser la parité pour ratifier un
engagement international l'inscription
dans la peine dans la constitution de la
peine de mort en 2007 était nécessaire
pour entériner le Pacte international
des droits civils et politiques
pour revenir quatrième raison sur une
interprétation jurisprudentielle du
Conseil constitutionnel comme en 1993
pour le droit des îles l'objet de la
proposition de loi soumise à notre
examen ne se peut se rattacher à aucune
de ses raisons de plus force est de
constater qu'il n'existe aujourd'hui
aucun consensus sur la manière de
constitutionnaliser l'IVG et le droit à
la contraception 6 propositions de loi
constitutionnelle ont été introduites à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat en
réaction à l'actualité américaine chaque
propose une version différente
l'inscription par défaut dans le titre 8
de la Constitution prévue par plusieurs
propositions de loi constitutionnelles
dont celle de la sénatrice Vogel n'est
pas satisfaisante l'intégration du droit
à l’interuption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception au sein du titre
consacré à l'autorité judiciaire juste
après l'abolition de la peine de mort a
de quoi surprendre et vous avez créé une
possible interférence du juge dans le
droit des femmes à avorter ce qui n'a
pas lieu d'être les propositions de
rattachement l'article premier ou
l'article 34 de la Constitution relatif
aux compétences du législateur ne font
pas plus consensus auprès des
constitutionnalismes de plus la
formulation soumise à notre examen
souvenait des difficultés importantes
elle laisse entendre que l'accès à ses
droits serait inconditionnel or le
législateur doit pouvoir en fixer les
conditions comme pour toutes les
libertés publiques enfin une procédure
de révision constitutionnelle à
l'initiative des parlementaires imposent
le recours aurait fait un random
conformément à l'article 89 de la
Constitution or il existe un risque réel
que cette initiative se retourne contre
les droits qu'elle est censée protéger
comme nous ont alerté toutes les
personnes auditionnées y compris les
auteurs recourir au référendum metré au
cœur d'une actualité bouillonnante un
sujet pour lequel il n'y a pas de remise
en et pourrait réveiller un réveil et
pour les favoriser pardon un réveil des
opposants n'oublions pas que l'enfer est
pavé de bonnes intentions pour toutes
ces raisons la commission des Lois vous
propose ne pas adopter cette proposition
de loi constitutionnelle
merci la parole est à monsieur Éric du
pont garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice
madame la ministre
cher Isabelle
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
madame la rapporteur madame la sénatrice
Mélanie Vogel mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
l'histoire je le crois profondément
fourmis
d'exemples de liberté de droit
fondamentaux conquis au prix du sang
des larmes que tous croyaient
définitivement acquis
et qui dans la stupeur ou l'indifférence
ont été balayées comme des fétus de
paille
c'est d'ailleurs l'histoire de la femme
qui nous offre les plus cruels exemples
car oui
les premiers droits qui disparaissent
sont souvent se défendre
et c'est ce que nous rappelle la
décision de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis le droit à l'avortement qu'on
croyait acquis depuis 50 ans en réalité
ne l'était pas
désormais
dans cette grande démocratie
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
n'est plus un droit garanti par la
Constitution fédérale et les États
fédérés sont libres de l'interdire ou de
la légaliser
cet exemple rend plus que jamais criant
de vérité les célèbres mots de Simone de
Beauvoir rapporté par Claudine Monteil
n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira d'une
crise politique économique ou religieuse
pour que les droits des femmes soient
remis en question ces droits ne sont
jamais acquis vous devrez rester
vigilant votre vie durant
parce que nous avons en effet désormais
la preuve que plus aucune démocratie
même la plus grande d'entre toutes n'est
à l'abri
parce qu'il nous faudra toujours rester
vigilant les auteurs de la présente
proposition de loi la sénatrice Mélanie
Vogel en tête propose d'inscrire
notamment le droit à un interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans notre
Constitution je veux ici les remercier
chaleureusement pour leur initiative
le 13 juillet dernier
en accord avec la première ministre
j'avais solennellement déclaré devant
cette assemblée qu'en tant que garde des
sceaux je soutiendrai avec force pour
les voir aboutir toutes les initiatives
parlementaires qui viseraient à
constitutionnaliser le droit à l'IVG me
voici donc au rendez-vous accompagné
de ma collègue Isabelle Rome alors
j'entends déjà s'élever et j'ai entendu
s'élever
des voix pour dire que le droit à l'IVG
est déjà suffisamment protégé en France
et que l'exemple américain n'est pas
transposable dans notre pays
qui aurait pu changer que le wokisme
serait transposé dans notre pays
on pourrait multiplier les exemples la
liste est immédiatement très longue
oui mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nuls ne peut nier que nos institutions
fonctionnent différemment
oui c'est vrai le Conseil
constitutionnel français n'est pas la
Cour suprême américaine
oui bien sûr les juges constitutionnels
français passaient et actuelles ont une
conscience accrue de leur rôle et jugent
régulièrement qu'il n'appartient pas au
Conseil constitutionnel de substituer
son appréciation à celle du législateur
c'est là l'usage républicain et l'esprit
de nos institutions oui il est vrai
encore que le droit à l'IVG a été
conforté au fil des ans depuis qu'il a
été consacré pour la première fois dans
notre droit par la loi veille du 17
janvier
1975 je pense ici à la dernière loi en
date du 2 mars 2022 qui a allongé le
délai légal pour recourir à l'IVG et le
porte désormais de 12 à 14 semaines je
pense aussi aux lois qui ont précédé
comme par exemple la loi du 4 août 2014
pour l'égalité réelle entre les hommes
et les femmes loi qui a supprimé le
critère de la situation de détresse pour
autant
je persiste et je signe
accompagner les initiatives
parlementaires pour graver dans le
marbre de notre Constitution le droit
fondamental à l'IVG me paraît
aujourd'hui pertinent en ces temps
troublé ou des projets politiques n'ont
certes pas cours dans cette hémicycle ou
si peu projet qui grandissent et rendent
possible des reculs drastiques pour le
droit des femmes d'abord
disons-le cette inscription aurait la
force du symbole
force du symbole qui n'est pas anodine
lorsque l'on parle de la loi suprême de
notre pays car oui la Constitution est
texte fondateur de notre État de droit
le choc commun des valeurs de notre
République et des libertés fondamentales
de notre société
dès lors quel beau symbole pour la
France
pays des droits de l'homme que celui
d'élever au plus haut rang de la
hiérarchie de ces normes le droit de la
femme à disposer monsieur le sénateur de
son propre corps
en ces temps de division
de perte de repères qu'elle plus beau
message envoyé à plus de la moitié de la
population française pour lui dire que
la Constitution lui garantit le droit à
disposer de son corps et donc le droit à
l'émancipation
car oui au-delà du symbole il y aurait
des conséquences concrètes alors que le
Conseil constitutionnel a rattaché l'IVG
à je cite la liberté de la femme qui
découle de l'article 2 de la Déclaration
des Droits de l'Homme et du Citoyen
inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution
permettrait de le consacrer enfin comme
un droit fondamental et non simplement
comme une liberté autonomie comme disent
les juristes constitutionnels mais il y
a une autre raison plus pragmatique sur
laquelle je veux insister un instant en
tant que garde des sceaux cette raison
elle est évident changer la Constitution
est beaucoup plus difficile
de changer la loi aujourd'hui consacré
par la loi si le droit à l'IVG était
demain protégé au niveau constitutionnel
il ne pourrait être remis en cause que
par le pouvoir constituant
car cela
nécessiterait à tout le moins que les
deux jambes et vous connaissez bien sur
la règle soit d'accord pour y consentir
première difficulté et pas des moindres
puis dans un second temps que le
Parlement réunit en congrès ou que nos
concitoyens par référendum valide ce qui
serait une régression terrible pour la
condition des femmes je veux ma pesantir
un instant
pour vous dire le fond de ma pensée
du fonds de mes tripes et donnez-moi
cette familiarité je vais vous montrer
comment la course des choses comme
disait Alain justifie que nous
soutenions l'inscription de l'IVG dans
notre Constitution alors que Simone Veil
s'exprimait le 26 novembre
1974 devant l'Assemblée nationale pour
porter cette grande loi elle inscrivait
son projet sous le signe de l'espérance
permettez-moi humblement de reprendre
ici ces mots alors qu'elle concluait son
discours pour convaincre les députés
encore hésitants
mesdames messieurs les députés je ne
suis pas de ceux et de celle qui
redoutent l'avenir c'est simple
Simone Veil croyez profondément que la
loi qu'elle portait alors
permettrait à la Société française de
progresser et l'avenir lui a bien
heureusement donné raison mais
mais mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
j'aimerais tant vous dire à cette
tribune un 19 octobre 2022 presque 50
ans après la légalisation de
l'avortement que non moi non plus je ne
redoute pas l'avenir j'aimerais tant
aujourd'hui ne pas être de ceux qui
tremblent face à l'avenir et aux
incertitudes qu'il charrie parfois
j'aimerais tant être de ceux qui
tranquille et d'un pas assuré avance
insouciant sur le chemin de la vie
croyons ce qui est acquis
et que ce qui est acquis est acquis
et que ce qui est là le sera pour
toujours j'aimerais tant enfin être de
ceux qui d'un revers de main balayant
les exemples étrangers et en particulier
l'exemple américain ou le droit recule
et avec lui souvent la condition des
femmes qui peut aujourd'hui dire
ce qui s'est produit aux États-Unis
ne pourrait pas se produire en France
soyons clairs qu'est-ce qui a amené la
décision de la Cour suprême américaine
l'élection d'un président populiste
légitimement élu certes disposant d'une
majorité au Sénat américain qui a pu
nommer au cours de son mandat 4 juges de
la Cour suprême
pardon
je pense pas que les membres du Conseil
constitutionnel soient nommés
exclusivement par un président de la
République fut-il populiste pardon il y
aurait là de quoi déstabiliser une
véritable institution je ne pense pas
que nos textes le permettent le constat
il est simple il est simple
politiquement et juridiquement un
président ou une présidente
disposant presque naturellement d'une
majorité pourrait je dis bien pourrait
revêtir en attaque actuelle du droit sur
cette avancée historique et démocratique
que représente le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse c'est d'ailleurs
le cas chez certains de nos voisins
européens c'est donc pour des raisons
totalement opposées à celles
de l'illustre Simone Veil
parce que précisément je redoute
l'avenir que je suis aujourd'hui
favorable à ce qu'on élève sa grande loi
celle de 1975 tel qu'aujourd'hui
modifiée sa grande conquête celle de
toutes les Françaises au sommet de la
hiérarchie des normes oui mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je veux mettre
le droit à l'IVG dans notre Constitution
la précisément où il ne sera pas
possible de l'en retirer sans l'accord
du Sénat
car je sais que là encore
il sera comme toujours le garant de nos
droits les plus fondamentaux je dis sans
aucune flagorerie inscrire le droit à
l'IVG dans la Constitution c'est aussi
s'assurer que le Sénat dans sa grande
sagesse soit assurée d'avoir le dernier
mot si d'aventure
un président une présidente et sa
majorité souhaitait l'abroger je crois
avec force au rôle presque informel mais
pourtant bien réel et durable du Sénat
en tant que garant de notre bien commun
de notre conscience collective
on dit souvent que le président
Mitterrand a été particulièrement
courageux d'abolir en 1981 la peine de
mort alors que le compatriote y était
majoritairement opposé mais ce que l'on
ne dit jamais c'est que le Sénat à lui
aussi tout aussi courageusement adopté
conforme 12 jours à peine après
l'Assemblée nationale la loi que portait
alors Robert Badinter mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ne vous trompez
pas inscrire aujourd'hui le droit à
l'IVG dans notre Constitution n'est pas
une mesure gadget
un artifice de communication ou un
mouvement de panique face à un exemple
étranger lointain inscrire le droit à
l'IVG cette liberté fondamentale et une
aliénable de la femme c'est une sécurité
pour toutes les femmes de ce pays
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
faites en sorte que personne ne puisse
abolir demain ce droit sans que vous
soyez consulté
les temps troublés et les remous ne sont
jamais loin dans le frêle esquif de la
démocratie qui mérite toute notre
attention en tant qu' ancien avocat mais
aussi en tant que citoyen j'ai toujours
essayé de faire en sorte que jamais l'on
oublie que notre démocratie notre État
de droit les libertés fondamentales
qu'il consacrent sont des biens précieux
nos joyaux communs pour lesquels il est
indispensable de se battre sans relâche
en tant que garde des sceaux il est
désormais de mon devoir de les préserver
c'est pourquoi je dise au sénatrice et
sénateurs que vous êtes ne prenons pas
de risque et protégeons autant que notre
droit le permet cette liberté
fondamentale des femmes qui ait le droit
à l'IVG que les choses soient claires ne
s'agit pas d'une entreprise aisée je le
dis avec gravité on ne doit toucher à la
constitution selon la formule consacrée
que d'une main tremblante c'est pourquoi
il nous faut avoir à l'esprit que le
détail de la rédaction qui serait
infinie retenue sera déterminant tout
comme le périmètre exact de la réforme
une rédaction inadaptée pour être en
effet conduire à consacrer un accès sans
condition à l'IVG je pense par exemple à
des IVG bien au-delà de la limite légale
en vigueur ce qui n'est pas souhaitable
nous en convenons une écriture
mal soupesée pour est également s’avérer
trop rigide et empêcher une adaptation
possible du dispositif actuel si
celle-ci s'avérait nécessaire comme cela
a d'ailleurs été le cas en mars dernier
il nous faudra au cours des débats ici
et à l'Assemblée rester très vigilant
sur les possibles et fait de bord il
nous faudra également rester vigilant
sur le choix de la place à laquelle
inscrire le dans la Constitution afin de
donner tout son sens à cette
reconnaissance toute sa cohérence au
regard naturellement des autres
dispositions constitutionnelles mais ma
crainte première
et elle semble fonder
c'est qu'il n'y ait justement pas se
débat
car j'ai pris acte du rejet du texte par
votre commission des Lois
laissez-moi vous dire avec la liberté
qui est la mienne que je le regrette
pas tant pour le détail de l'écriture de
la proposition de loi de la sénatrice
Vogel sur laquelle je rejoins d'ailleurs
un certain nombre de crainte de la
rapporteur Agnès canaillé je le regrette
car cette décision souveraine de votre
commission acte au fond un refus de
principe de constitutionnaliser le droit
à l'IVG
il n'est même pas question pour la
commission de travailler sur une
meilleure rédaction possible non il
s'agit d'un refus pur et simple qui
condamne par anticipation toute
initiative d'où qu'elles viennent or
vous le savez sans doute sans Laval du
Sénat le verrou sacré de notre
Constitution ne peut être levée il faut
pourtant que le débat vive
j'espère donc que l'hémicycle dira non
nous ne fermons pas la porte d'emblée
essayons d'avancer ensemble sur cette
proposition ou celle de la présidente
berger ou panneau essayons d'entendre
les pour mais aussi bien sûr les contre
essayons d'entendre les craintes pour
les apaiser et surtout travaillons
ensemble pour trouver la meilleure
rédaction possible et de ne pas manquer
cette occasion alors que les planètes
s'alignent aujourd'hui pour permettre
enfin cette Constitution réalisation je
le dis et je le regrette si le Sénat est
prête à avancer avec prudence et sans
idéologie sur cette question le
gouvernement répondra présent de fait il
répond déjà présent aujourd'hui devant
vous car oui le gouvernement vous l'avez
compris est favorable à la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
je le dis également le gouvernement
répondra présent pour soutenir chacune
des initiatives parlementaires qui sont
nombreuses en la matière les rédactions
proposées sont diverses et je suis
persuadé que ces initiatives je pense à
celle de la présidente Aurore berger à
sa collègue Marie-Pierre rexin qui porte
toutes les deux avec force et Constance
ce combat nous permettront d'atteindre
je le crois la meilleure rédaction
possible avant de conclure mon propos
je veux dire ici à ceux qui nous
regardent il ne s'agit pas de livrer tel
ou tel parlementaire à la vindique des
réseaux sociaux comme cela a pu être
fait
je pense
à la présidente
de la présentation de sa proposition de
loi j'ai éprouvé personnellement depuis
deux ans et sur de très nombreux textes
votre engagement sans farine madame la
sénatrice canaillé pour la défense de
notre État de droit et des droits de nos
concitoyens le débat politique il est
fait bien sûr de désaccord et tout le
monde a dans cette hémicycle le droit
d'exprimer librement ses opinions sans
crainte d'être inquiété le débat
politique il est aussi fait d'accord et
de convergence patiemment construit sur
le chemin du compromis avançons ensemble
sur ce chemin du compromis mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs comme nous
l'avons fait tant de fois
sans démagogie sans idéologie pour
renforcer à nouveau les droits de
l'homme qui sont cet après-midi ceux de
la femme
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame Isabelle Rome
ministre délégué chargé d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes de la diversité
et de l'égalité des chances
madame la Présidente
pour votre discours puissant merci pour
vos mots
c'est la première proposition de loi
qu'il me revient de soutenir aujourd'hui
devant vous comme ministre délégué
auprès de la première ministre chargé de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
je suis fière qu'il s'agisse de celle
consistante à inscrire le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans notre Constitution
d'entourer ce droit conquis de haute
lutte après des années de combat
féministes et grâce à l'opiniâtreté et
la force de Simone Veil de l'entourer
d'un rempart
car il faut le préserver le protéger
contre les menaces devant mauvais ou les
courants réactionnaires
se rempart doit être à la hauteur de ce
qui font notre République une libre
égale fraternelle
c'est pourquoi il est nécessaire
d'inscrire le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution du 4 octobre 1958 vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le garde des
sceaux il est beaucoup plus difficile de
changer une constitution que de changer
la loi qu'une autre loi une autre
majorité peut défaire en quelques mois
parce que non madame la rapporteur
malgré le respect que je peux avoir pour
vos travaux nous ne sommes à l'abri de
rien quel américaine aurait imaginé il y
a deux ou trois ans encore voir
s'effondrer la protection de ce droit
soumis désormais aux aléas politiques
des différents États membres des
États-Unis
aurait-on pensé il y a moins de deux ans
au sein même de l'Union européenne que
des états reviennent sur le droit à
l'IVG en autorisant les femmes à avorter
seulement en cas de viol ou de graves
danger ou en les contraignant à écouter
le cœur du futur avant de prendre leur
décision
depuis 2017 le gouvernement et la
majorité n'ont au contraire cessé de
renforcer la législation en matière de
droits sexuels et reproductifs en
donnant un accès gratuit à la
contraception pour toutes les femmes
jusqu'à 25 ans
en allongeant les délais d'accès à l'IVG
de 12 à 14 semaines de grossesse en
prévoyant le tiers payant intégral de
l'IVG afin notamment d'en assurer la
confidentialité et en soutenant
résolument le planning familial dont les
financements seront augmentés pour le
lancement de leur chat visant à lutter
contre la désinformation
ce combat avec François Brune ministre
de la Santé nous le poursuivons en
rendant dès l'an prochain la pilule du
lendemain gratuite sans ordonnance pour
toutes les femmes ce combat avec Eric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sous nous le
menons cet après-midi avec la
représentation nationale et je remercie
madame la sénatrice belhadimogel de nous
en donner l'occasion à travers cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle une
proposition que porte également la
majorité parlementaire emmené par Aurore
berger
je remercie par ailleurs l'ensemble des
parlementaires engagés et
particulièrement les membres de la
délégation à l'égalité femme homme du
Sénat conduite par Annick billon avec
laquelle j'échange de manière très
régulière et très constructive
ce combat la France le mène également
hors de ses frontières c'est dans ce
sillon que le Président de la République
a affirmé le 19 janvier dernier devant
les euros députés vouloir inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans la Charte des droits
fondamentaux de l'Union européenne
et c'est dans ce sillon que s'inscrit
notre diplomatie féministe dans le forum
génération égalité organisé à Paris en
juillet 2021 a constitué le point
culminant la contribution de la France
pour les droits sexuels et reproductifs
à l'échelle internationale ce hisse à
hauteur de 400 millions d'euros sur cinq
ans
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs les droits sexuels et
reproductifs conditionnent tous les
autres droits des femmes
des tricotés et cornés ou nier ses
droits constituent assurément une forme
de violence fondée sur le genre
parce que les droits des femmes sont des
droits humains ils ne sont ni chez
câbles niérarchisables
ce ne sont pas des droits à moitié mais
des droits fondamentaux
inaliénables qu'il convient de protéger
et de consolider
aucune femme aucune de nos filles ne
doit vivre en France dans la peur d'être
un jour dénoncé arrêter juger pour avoir
avorté comme ce fut le cas de
Marie-Claire en 1973 jugé au tribunal de
Bobigny et remarquablement défendu par
Gisèle Halimi cette garantie notre
République doit leur apporter c'est pour
toutes ces raisons que comme la déjà
exprimé la première ministre le
Gouvernement est favorable à la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
et n'en déplaise à l'extrême droite qui
malgré le vernis qu'elle tente de nous
montrer n'a jamais été et ne sera jamais
l'allié des droits des femmes nous
devons être collectivement lucide la
menace d'un retour en arrière n'est pas
une chimère
l'exemple américain le pays d'Elizabeth
kedistement
s'attaquer à l'avortement c'est
s'attaquer à toutes les femmes et c'est
s'attaquer à la liberté le gouvernement
sera toujours du côté des femmes et de
la liberté je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci
quand nous passons à la discussions de
la motion tendante à opposer la question
préalable
monsieur Stéphane Ravier a déposé une
notion distribuée sous le numéro 1
pendant à opposer la question préalable
au texte en discussion la parole est
donc à Monsieur Stéphane Ravier pour la
motion et pour 3 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
l'immigration jusqu'au remplacement
l'islamisme jusque dans nos écoles
l'insécurité jusqu'à la barbarie la
fiscalité jusqu'aux racket la précarité
jusqu'à la pauvreté de masse les sujets
graves les sujets graves ne manquent pas
en France mais nous voilà en train de
perdre un temps précieux en discutant
d'une problématique importée des
États-Unis sans aucun rapport avec la
réalité de notre pays et c'est pourtant
ce dont les auteurs de ce texte se
réclament dans l'exposé des motifs vous
êtes hors sujet je dirais même qu'il n'y
a pas de sujets c'est pourquoi je vous
propose mes chers collègues d'enterrer
ce texte avant même son examen un texte
dangereux
inutile qui permet à ces auteurs de
faire de l'agit propre comme la lui-même
analysé et dénoncer dans le Figaro du
jour l'ancien secrétaire général du
Conseil constitutionnel Jean-Éric Shel
vous avez voté le prolongement de
l'avortement jusqu'à 16 semaines
d'aménorrhées dans un texte de loi du
mois de mars ces attaques envers la vie
ne vous suffisent-elles pas c'est
complètement anachronique de dire que
l'avortement est menacé dans notre pays
quand il existe un délit d'entrave de
deux ans d'emprisonnement et 30 000
euros d'amende pour quiconque tenterait
d'y opposer un avis contraire en 2021 se
sont encore 223 000 avortements qui ont
été réalisés à gravats l'hiver
démographique français cela ne vous
suffit toujours pas il y a des
impératifs de santé dans notre pays dans
ce texte nous détourne l'avortement
invoqué dans le cadre pour les cas
d'urgence dans la loi veille est devenue
un avortement banalisé encouragé en 2022
pourtant il faut le rappeler ce n'est
pas un acte anodin
moi je suis plutôt inquiet détournures
que prennent les propositions actuelles
je vous rappelle cet amendement sur
l'avortement à 9 mois 9 mois en
invoquant une détresse psychosociale
vous considérez que cet infanticide
légalisé est un progrès je considère que
c'est une union mini qui vous déshonore
souvent les femmes avortent sous la
contrainte
psychologique ou économique
accompagnant-les soutenons-les elle est
là la mission du politique il est là
notre devoir de plus sur le plan
juridique ce texte vient encombrer la
Constitution dans un dans son article 8
pourtant consacrer au pouvoir judiciaire
la Constitution régie l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics elle n'est pas une
charte de droit j'ai entendu que les
auteurs de la loi souhaitaient
constitutionnaliser un droit pour
empêcher les lois régressives je trouve
pourtant que l'adjectif régressif et
tout à fait celui qui correspond aux
infâmes loi bioéthiques que nous avons
voté que vous vous avez voté ces
dernières années et quelque chose me dit
que le pire est encore devant nous
cette proposition de loi consignée par 5
présidents de groupe écologistes
socialistes communistes connaissances et
radicaux nous donne à voir un front
commun c'est une clarification de
position pour une plus grande
clarification
contre la motion merci
je crois que vous pouvez le dire
toujours je suis toujours
c'est pas grave madame vosgel vous avez
la parole merci madame la Présidente je
vais vous dire une chose je me suis
ravier j'aurais presque envie de vous
remercier évidemment je ne vais pas le
faire mais vous êtes exactement en train
de démontrer pourquoi nous sommes en
train de faire ce que nous faisons
comme le dit
comme
le souvent et si souvent si bien
Laurence Rossignol il n'y a pas
d'exception française
ut égard à l'extrême droite l'extrême
droite française elle est comme
l'extrême droite partout elle s'oppose
au droit des femmes elle s'oppose aux
droits sexuels et reproductifs elle
déteste tous les acquis de la République
tous les progrès que les féministes sont
acquis de haute lutte elles détestent
l'égalité des droits et la liberté et
n'ayez aucun doute chers collègues ça
détermination allait détruire si par le
pire des malheurs de l'histoire elle
arrive au pouvoir en France et total
évidente et parfaitement transparente on
nous raconte que le droit est l'IVG
n'est pas menacé en France qu'aucun
parti politique en France ne peut
revenir sur le droit à l'avortement et
bien voilà la force politique qui a fait
42% des voix au second tour d'action
présidentielle vient de vous prouver le
contraire alors oui c'est vrai il y a
une clarification il y a ceux dans cette
hémicycle celles et ceux qui sont en
faveur des droits et des libertés
fondamentales y compris les droits et
libertés fondamentales des femmes et
celles et ceux qui ne le sont pas alors
chers collègues la question de quel côté
êtes-vous je vous le demande encore une
fois surtout qui dans cette émission
tiennent encore à tenir l'extrême droite
et son projet à distance prenez la
mesure du moment historique que nous
vivons les fascisme progressent et avec
eux les attaques de nos droits les plus
fondamentaux personne ne sait qui
gouvernera à la France en 2027 quelle
sera la prochaine majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale personne nous sommes ici une
majorité je crois dans cet assemblée à
rappeler notre attachement au droit à
l'IVG et bien prouvons-le
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
même la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente alors la
commission des lois n'a pas pu se réunir
mais j'aimais un avis évidemment
défavorable à cette question préalable
il est nécessaire même si nous avons des
oppositions justement que le débat
démocratique se fasse ici au Sénat de
manière calme et serein et c'est ici la
force du Sénat de pouvoir débattre en
respectant les convictions des uns et
des autres merci quelle est la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
nous pensions avoir exposé tous les
arguments qui nous étaient venus en tête
nous avons partagé d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de ces arguments évidemment
et puis voilà que monsieur le sénateur
ravier nous chamboule
au fond monsieur le sénateur
l'imaginaire voyez-vous et souvent le
dernier refuge de la liberté
et alors
vous nous donnez une formidable raison
de voter ce texte
non mais imaginons vous voyez imaginons
je le disais à l'instant
oui bah c'est le dernier refuge de la
liberté imaginons qu'un jour imaginons
qu'un jour vous soyez au pouvoir ce qu'a
dit une plaise
moi je pense que l'avortement est
sérieusement menacé dans ce pays ouais
ah ouais
ouais
[Applaudissements]
bon et puis je vais vous dire une chose
là quand on parle de droit de l'homme et
surtout de droit de la femme on n'est
jamais hors sujet monsieur le sénateur
voilà la question elle se pose quand on
vous voit quand on vous entend vous
exprimez il peut mariniste d'ailleurs il
est il est mourien monsieur le sénateur
on va le dire il a il a il a changé de
de bord ouais un peu un peu plus un peu
plus allé et un peu plus à droite encore
mauvais il était il a été élu sous
l'étiquette de Marine Le Pen il est
parti plus à droite encore bon nous
verrons tout ça ça c'est de la petite
politique politicienne mais merci merci
de nous avoir apporté ce témoignage vous
voyez moi moi monsieur le sénateur les
mots moi monsieur le sénateur les mots
que vous avez utilisé à la tribune je
n'aurais jamais
osé les prononcer merci d'être là
vraiment merci
monsieur le garde je vais passer aux
explications de vote je voudrais vous
rappeler que s'agissant d'une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle il
y aura un scrut bien public et je passe
la parole à Monsieur iacovelli
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la France elle ne vit pas dans un vase
clos elle me dit pas en vase clos les
débats de société qui transcendent les
frontières et donc on ne peut pas rester
insensible et sourd aux attentes au
droit des femmes qui traversent les
différents pays et d'ailleurs pas
seulement outre-Atlantique je pense sur
le continent européen je pense à
l'Italie qui dernièrement avec melon il
souhaite développer des
d'ailleurs vos amis monsieur ravier vos
amis qui sont aux responsabilités donc
Meloni des alternatives à l'avortement
et notamment en donnant une allocation
pour éviter d'avorter
en Pologne en Pologne d'autres amis
monsieur ravier en Pologne a rendu un
arrêté
s'il vous plaît monsieur ravier monsieur
ravier s'il vous plaît
de grossesse en Hongrie un autre ami à
vous monsieur ravier le mois dernier a
durci la réglementation et que tout le
monde le sache aujourd'hui vous savez
c'est qu'est-ce qu'ils ont demandé ils
ont demandé aux femmes qui souhaitent
avorter d'écouter le cœur de leur Fétude
du fœtus des enfants d'accord pour
éviter d'avorter voilà c'est ça la
réalité aujourd'hui de votre famille
politique à travers le drop et c'est ça
la réalité des attaques contre
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
alors moi chers collègues j'ai quatre
questions à vous poser quatre questions
à vous poser est-ce qu'on est en tant
que législateur est-ce qu'on est s'il
vous plaît est-ce qu'on est en tant que
législateur est-ce que nous soutenons le
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse cette grande loi de progrès
est-ce que nous soutenons le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps est-ce
que nous soutenons en tant que Français
nous sommes attachés à ce que la France
qui reste ce phare des droits dans un
océan de pays qui attaque effectivement
effectivement les droits des femmes à
travers le monde et est-ce que nous
souhaitons et là je pose la question
aussi au gouvernement est-ce que nous
souhaitons que par cette
constitutionnalisation nous puissions
pousser le gouvernement à faire en sorte
que ce droit soit effectif dans
l'ensemble des territoires et notamment
dans la ruralité alors mes chers
collègues je voudrais juste finir non
merci chers bas
monsieur le castor bah vous avez la
parole
je suis désolé je donnerai la même non
je donnerai le même temps de parole pour
tout le monde je rappelle ces deux
minutes et c'est pas 10 secondes de plus
ou 30
de la République
encore capable aujourd'hui de discuter
sereinement d'un sujet essentiel pour la
vie de notre société
sommes-nous capables de laisser un
instant de côté les patients et de faire
un travail utile pour notre pays je le
souhaite
sur le garde des sceaux vous avez
invoqué Simone Veil
bien que j'ai été l'un de ses plus
proches collaborateurs et que je lui
sois resté fidèle jusqu'au bout je ne
parlerai pas en son nom nul n'a le droit
de le faire
mais
le vrai combat c'est elle qui l'a mené
le vrai courage c'est elle qui l'a eu
et il importe aujourd'hui encore de lui
en rendre hommage car les équilibres que
la suite trouver sont ceux sur lesquels
nous vivons 50 ans un peu moins après et
c'est très important de le dire ne
déplaçons pas ces équilibres alors
monsieur le garde des sceaux je ne
comprends pas exactement votre position
vous avez parlé de symboles de beaux
symboles d'accord pour les beaux
symboles mais ici nous légiférons et
quand nous légifierons sur la
constitution nous ne cherchons pas des
symboles nous cherchons à être utiles à
notre pays or à la fin de votre propos
vous n'avez pas manqué et vous ne
pouviez pas faire autrement
de prendre des distances à l'égard du
texte qui nous est proposé et de montrer
que celui-ci devrait être amélioré sur
bien des points parce qu'il ne vous
paraît pas apporter toutes les garanties
possibles par ailleurs le gouvernement
n'a pas pris l'initiative d'un projet de
loi et nous condamnerait mais
sur ce sujet
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre sauvegardesseaux chers
collègues le groupe de l'Union centriste
ne votera pas cette motion tendance à
opposer la question préalable parce que
le débat a eu lieu sereinement
commission
madame Vogel a été invité à présenter sa
proposition de loi
ça a été un vote de la commission des
lois qui l'a permis en jarc
la rapporteur a fait un travail qui est
un travail équilibré et le débat a pu
avoir lieu le principe d'une discussion
générale c'est de permettre à tout un
chacun d'exposer son opinion et je
trouve qu'à l'instant on se parle le
débat des raps donc j'aurais pour le
coup compte de du groupe de l'Union
centriste l'occasion de rappeler la
position majoritaire dans le respect de
ceux qui voteront différemment et donc
je souhaite au nom de mon groupe que ce
débat puisse avoir lieu et que le calme
revienne
merci chers collègues alors je vais
consulter le Sénat sur la motion
tendante à opposée la question préalable
je rappelle que l'adoption de cette
motion entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion
en application de l'article 59 du
règlement le scrutin public ordinaire et
de droit le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 7
sur la motion numéro 1 compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordée par les sénateurs au groupe
politique et notifié à la présidence
nombre de votants 345 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 345 pour l'adoption 1
contre 344 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
dans la suite de la discussion générale
je vais donner la parole à Monsieur
Stéphane Artano pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 4 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame monsieur les
ministres monsieur prénom la commission
des lois madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira
d'une crise politique économique ou
religieuse pour que les droits des
femmes soient remis en question ces
droits ne sont jamais acquis vous devrez
rester vigilant votre vie durant oui
vigilants nous devons l'être mes chers
collègues c'est avertissement de Simone
de Beauvoir et tristement prémonitoire
et d'actualité en effet 50 ans après
l'adoption la loi veille force et de
constater que le droit l'avortement est
loin d'être acquis entre interdiction
totale et restriction il faut savoir que
les avortements que clandestin provoque
en moyenne la mort d'une femme toutes
les 9 minutes dans le monde sont livrés
à un commentaire la jurisprudence de
l'accord suprême américaine je
retiendrai que le droit à l'avortement
et l'une des premières cibles des
conservateurs excessifs alors j'entends
et d'une certaine façon je comprends les
arguments mis en avant par notre
rapporteur il n'y a rien de faux à dire
que ce procédé n'empêcherait pas d'une
part la possibilité d'une nouvelle
révision constitutionnelle
afin de faire céder la disposition
protectrice d'autre part son inscription
pourrait anticiper participer pardon à
une inflation des droits
constitutionnels assimilable à une à
l'inflation législative les reproches
fait à la loi bavarde se reporteraient
sur la constitution et plus largement
sur le bloc de constitutionnalités à
devenir trop large et perdant en
efficacité à cela vous ajoutez que le
Conseil constitutionnel défend déjà
l'accès à l'IVG comme composante de la
liberté de la femme laquelle découle de
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 d'un
point de vue du droit tout cela se tient
de tant qu'en France fort heureusement
ne ceux qui voudraient remettre en cause
l'IVG et la contraception sont
extrêmement minoritaires nous sommes
donc face à un texte
qui est d'un point de vue juridique on
peut justifier qu'il ne soit pas
nécessaire d'un point de vue social non
plus pour autant j'en suis cosignataire
de cette proposition portée par notre
collègue et d'un niveau gel et je la
vauterai bien évidemment en premier lieu
parce qu'il faut y voir un moyen de
défense droit des femmes dans notre pays
en second lieu parce que c'est une façon
de dire aussi que la France ne cèdera
pas à l'obscurantisme et aux populismes
montrons l'exemple qu'on doute cèdent au
recul des idées pour la liberté et
l'émancipation
continuons à affirmer que les droits à
l'IVG à la contraception ne sauraient
être malmenés à l'avenir ils ne sont pas
tributaires d'interprétation il est trop
précaire de se résoudre sur un tel sujet
à la seule interprétation depuis 2002
par les juges d'un article datant de
plus de deux siècles
par ailleurs un revirement de
jurisprudence et d'interprétation serait
trop simple à justifier j'entends déjà
ceux qui nous expliqueraient qu'au sens
strict ou historique l'article 2 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et des
citoyens ne se réfèrent ni à l'IVG ni à
la contraception autrement dit ce qui
est arrivé aux États-Unis pourrait
arriver chez nous également il faudra
aller au-delà comme le propose cette
proposition de loi la
constitutionnalisation d'un droit est un
processus efficace vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le garde de Sceaux afin de
sanctuariser le dans le texte suprême un
droit autonome et le protéger de toutes
volonté politique que ce soit celle du
législateur ou des juges bien sûr dit
qu'il y a un droit constitutionnel
fondamental ne sera pas suffisant à
faire qu'il le soit nous devons
poursuivre nos efforts ça a été rappelé
pour qu'il soit effectif qu'il
s'inscrivent dans les mœurs l'éducation
des jeunes générations est essentielle
de ce point de vue
il faut aussi empêcher toute restriction
de personnels et de suppression de sang
pratiquons l'avortement lors de
restructuration hospitalière et nous en
sommes évidemment bien d'accord vous
l'aurez compris dans sa grande majorité
le groupe RDSE va en faveur de cette
proposition de loi
la parole est à Madame Muriel jourdat
pour le groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
le Président je garde des sourds
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues à l'instar de la
quasi-totalité et des sénateurs du
groupe les républicains je ne voterai
pas à ce texte je ne voterai pas et j'ai
peu de temps pour vous expliquer et
pourquoi je ne voterai pas et je risque
d'être un peu brutal je le voterai tout
simplement pas parce que c'est de la
mauvaise législation
c'est de la mode des gestion et nous
sommes essentiellement des législateurs
ici nous ne sommes pas des militants
quand nous rentrons dans cette hémicycle
nous ne décernons pas des brevets de
Morales nous ne faisons pas de la
politique fiction nous faisons la loi et
ce serait à l'évidence de la mauvaise
loi ce serait la mauvaise loi d'abord
parce que c'est un texte de réaction
réaction effectivement à une décision
qui a été prise par la Cour suprême des
États-Unis et qui vise à renvoyer aux
Etats fédérés le soin de légiférer sur
l'IVG
le fait que à moins de 6 propositions de
loi aient été déposées des montres bien
que c'est en réaction à cet événement
que ce texte nous est proposé
aujourd'hui visant à constitutionnaliser
la liberté des femmes de recourir à
l'ivier la réaction précède toujours la
réflexion et elle nous fait envisager
une situation
par la fenêtre i3 et déformante de
l'émotion plutôt que de l'envisager dans
toute sa complexité
le deuxième défaut de cette législation
et que vraisemblablement sans de vouloir
elle met à mal notre ordonnancement
juridique alors je ne suis pas une
fétichiste du droit et je pense que le
droit n'est qu'un outil mais avons qu'en
France nous avons une boîte à outils
assez garnie et si nous voulons qu'elle
reste opérationnelle il faut qu'elle
soit toujours rangée or la Constitution
contient l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics et aussi affirme un certain
nombre de droits fondamentaux le Conseil
constitutionnel nous indique quant à lui
dans une jurisprudence constante que le
droit des femmes la liberté des femmes
d'avoir recours à l'IVG et la
déclinaison d'un de ses droits
fondamentaux mais si nous inscrivons
dans la Constitution la déclinaison de
tous les droits fondamentaux au mieux
nous en serons une espèce de code
général au pire nous la rendrons lisible
et nous en détruirons tous les effets
cela est à peu près intangible les chers
collègues et enfin je reprends là les
mots de monsieur le garde des sceaux ce
texte est fait pour être un symbole la
loi n'est pas un symbole la Constitution
n'est pas un symbole nous sommes tous
touchés ici par le cas des femmes
américaines qui suivent les États dans
lequel ils vont nous pourront plus
profiter de cette liberté d'avoir
recours à l'IVG et nous l'entendons
parfaitement mais même si la France est
le phare a été le phare des libertés
individuelles et de l'universalisme nous
ne pouvons pas nous servir de notre
Constitution comme d'un message à
envoyer aux femmes du monde entier
un texte de loi est faite pour produire
de l'effet pas pour être symbolique
alors il m'échappe pas que l'effet
escompté de ce texte et de protéger sa
liberté des femmes de recourir à l'IVG
mais là encore le chat collègue la
Constitution n'est pas un coffre-fort ou
alors le législateur en alcool depuis
fort longtemps puisque depuis 1958 nous
n'avons pas modifié la Constitution
moins de 24 fois et cet effet de guerre
protecteur mais d'autres auront le temps
de le développer après moi et puis
surtout les protéger de quoi
quel danger menace aujourd'hui la
liberté des femmes
quel danger le menace nous avons eu
récemment des élections nationales
quelle partie politique a développé dans
son programme labrogation de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
aucun aucun car cela n'est pas à l'ordre
du jour personne en France n'est opposé
à l'IVG
ça ne veut pas dire que personne ne le
soit à titre personnel mais chacun garde
ça dans son fort intérieur aujourd'hui
et c'est précisément tout le danger de
ce texte car vous savez que pour aboutir
cette procédure de votre conduire au
référendum proposé par le Président de
la République chacun sait que les
résultats des référendum est clairement
sur l'état de l'opinion sur la question
posée que sur la popularité de celui qui
pose la question tout cela est très
hasardeuse me semble-t-il et surtout
lorsque nous avons référendum nous avons
un débat et lors de ce débat ce qui
gardait leur opposition à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans leur fort
intérieur et bien on se rend amenés tout
à fait légitimement à le déposer sur la
face publique et nous allons arriver à
avec ce texte nous allons arriver à la
situation dans laquelle pour protéger la
liberté des femmes d'une menace qui est
inexistante en France et nous les gîtons
pour le seul français et pour le droit
français nous allons remettre en débat
une liberté qui semblait pour les femmes
acquises depuis des décennies alors mes
chers collègues si véritablement vous
voulez protéger ne votez pas ce texte
leg la parole est un monsieur Pierre
Jean verzelaine pour le groupe les
indépendants et pour 4 minutes chers
collègues
monsieur le garde des sceaux mes chers
collègues avant janvier 75 c'était hier
l'avortement était un délit pénal
sanctionné jusqu'à 50 prisons les
médecins pouvaient être condamnés à une
interdiction un interdiction d'exercer
et les femmes concernées elles étaient
contraintes d'aller à l'étranger ou de
recourir à des avortements clandestins
la reconnaissance de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse a été le fruit
d'un long combat on se souvient du
Manifeste des 343
on se souvient de l'acquittement de la
jeune Marie-Claire on se souvient moins
de la première tentative très encadrée
de légalisation qui a échoué en 1973 et
porté par Michel Poniatowski à l'époque
ce sujet a profondément divisé la
société les débats au Parlement ce sont
déroulés dans une rare violence
Simone Veil soutenu par Jacques Chirac
par une partie de la majorité et par
l'opposition des fondations texte avec
acharnement malgré les attaques
personnelles son combat c'était celui de
toutes les femmes
lors de son discours devant l'Assemblée
nationale elle déclara aucune femme ne
recourt de gaieté de cœur à l'avortement
cette phrase
c'est évidemment toujours une réalité
car même s'il s'agit d'une décision
réfléchie pesée et assumer un avortement
demeure et demeure a toujours un
événement marquant un drame dans la vie
d'une femme
suppression de la notion de détresse
allongement des délais d'avortement
remboursement à 100% par la sécu depuis
la loi s'est adapté et a été améliorée
nous pouvons ici tous ensemble en
convenir la France n'est pas aujourd'hui
je vais je vais dire à l'heure à
laquelle on parle menacer de connaître
un retour en arrière sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs aucune parole crédible ou
reconnu comme tel ou en tout cas qui a
une certaine audience ne leur réclame ou
ne le revendique
bien attaché à la protection
fondamentale de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse certains des
collègues de mon groupe ne voient pas la
justification juridique de cette
démarche
il considère qu'il s'agit d'un texte
déclaratif qui n'aura pas d'issue
positive un symbole qui ne fera pas
avancer concrètement l'accès à l'IVG à
l'avortement et qu'enfin toucher à la
constitution sur des questions
sociétales revient ouvrir une boîte de
Pandore c'est la raison pour laquelle
certains élus de notre groupe
s'abstiendront contre cette proposition
sur le sujet de l'IVG nous sommes forcés
de constater que toutes les autres
démocraties n'avancent pas au même
rythme que la France au sein même de
l'Union européenne en Pologne Unoa vient
de restreindre l'avortement qui n'est
plus autorisé qu'en cas de viol ou
d'inceste de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique la Cour suprême a remis en
cause l'avortement chaque État est
désormais libre d'interdire l'avortement
une dizaine d'ailleurs ont déjà commencé
à faire marche arrière à nos frontières
en Italie madame Meloni qui vient de
remporter les élections assume de
favoriser le droit à ne pas recourir à
l'IVG preuve que le combat de la liberté
d'avorter n'est pas acquise là nous ne
voyons penser qu'il est intouchable
madame la sénatrice
il y a certaines des convictions que
vous portez que je ne partage pas votre
conception de la société n'est pas
vraiment la mienne
le propos que vous avez tenu tout à
l'heure est un peu agressif un peu
culpabilisant et je suis pas certain que
ce soit la meilleure manière de défendre
la cause que vous portez néanmoins comme
d'autres collègues du groupe je voterai
en faveur de vos propositions car ce
qu'une loi a fait une autre peu la
défaire ce sera beaucoup plus difficile
quand elle sera inscrite et gravée dans
le marbre de la Constitution
pour en terminer je fais remarquer que
ça demande pas de saveur de voir celles
et ceux qui remettent en cause nos
institutions qui parlent souvent de la
Sixième République finalement s'appuyer
sur la constitution voulue par le
général de Gaulle pour protéger un droit
fondamental et essentiel des femmes de
ce pays je voulais souligner cette
avancée ainsi comme je l'exprimais dans
mon propos fidèle à l'ADN du groupe les
indépendants chacun votera selon ses
convictions merci merci chers collègues
la parole est au président Guillaume
Gontard pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire pour 4 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues
qu'est-ce qu'une constitution
les étudiants en première année de droit
et de sciences politiques dès leur
premier cours de droit constitutionnels
sont soumis à cette épineuse question et
la réponse tient en trois points
premièrement un traité d'organisation
des pouvoirs publics garantissant leur
séparation deuxièmement un système de
subordination des normes et
troisièmement un corpus de droits et de
valeurs la Constitution est notre norme
suprême chacun sait ici la force
juridique comme symbolique du test
constitutionnel comme des principes à
valeur constitutionnelles quand
j'entends sur nos bancs inscrire le
droit fondamental à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution ne servirait pas ou peu je
suis saisi par la surprise encore plus
après les propos abject du sénateur
ravier alors non la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel ne protège pas
positivement le droit à l'IVG
et oui son inscription dans le marbre
constitutionnel beaucoup plus dur à
tailler que le calcaire de la loi est
une protection considérable accordée aux
femmes
dont rêve beaucoup à travers le monde et
que l'on pleure de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique c'est un truisme qu'il faut
étrangement répéter et vous avez raison
monsieur le ministre de le faire il est
bien plus complexe de modifier le texte
constitutionnel que la loi a fortiori
dans notre cinquième république
rationalisée où l'exécutif tient le
Parlement dans sa main de l'autre côté
des Alpes malgré sa victoire d'une
ampleur inédite la coalition des schiste
de la droite n'est pas en mesure de
changer la constitution et c'est un
soulagement
comme l'a rappelé le monsieur le garde
des sceaux ne prenons pas de risque le
Funès destin politique de nos voisins
transalpins nous rappelle d'ailleurs que
si l'IVG n'est pas aujourd'hui menacé
dans notre pays il faut profiter de ce
moment pour le protéger avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard pareil
occasion ne se représentera pas
d'aussitôt alors comment inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans le corpus de droit et
de valeur qu'est notre Constitution ce
débat est légitime et il est vrai que
dans la tradition constitutionnelle
française ses droits et valeurs sont
plutôt énumérées dans les textes
historiques qui font la grandeur de
notre pays la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen et le magnifique
préambule de la Constitution de 1946
text rattaché au Préambule de la
Constitution de 1958 mais ce n'est pas
une exclusive et on retrouve tout au
long de ces articles de la Constitution
nombre de valeurs cardinales et de droit
fondamentaux de notre République parmi
lesquels l'égalité la laïcité la
souveraineté nationale l'abolition de la
peine de mort
alors que faire écrire une nouvelle
Charte des droits des femmes pour
compléter la trop masculine Déclaration
des Droits de l'Homme et du Citoyen
renforcer l'article 1 qui assure déjà la
parité politique crée un article 66-2
pour interdire l'entrave à l'IVG ce
débat est fécond et légitime mais ce
n'est pas le débat du jour nous ne
souhaitons pas aujourd'hui sur la base
de ce texte engagé un processus de
révision constitutionnelle d'origine
parlementaire qui déboucherait sur un
effet de référendum nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui envoyer un message politique
au gouvernement pour le rassurer pour
lui signifier qu'il trouvera ici au
Sénat une majorité pour faire adopter un
projet de loi inscrivant le droit
fondamental à l'IVG dans notre
Constitution
libre à lui libre à vous monsieur le
garder saut de choisir la rédaction qui
vous conviendra le mieux de convoquer
une commission spéciale des mines
juristes ou même une convention
citoyenne pour écrire une charge du
droit des femmes ce que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui c'est que le Sénat se
prononce en faveur de ce principe en
faveur de ce symbole politiquement
politique extrêmement fort qui rayonnera
partout
je vais d'abord madame la rapportant
m'attacher à votre rapport selon vous
l'IVG ne fait l'objet d'aucune remise en
cause aujourd'hui en France et bien je
ne partage pas votre sérénité les
courants hostiles à l'IVG n'ont jamais
désarmées depuis 1975 il dispose de
moyens financiers considérables drainer
un international s'appuie sur des
institutions puissantes comme la
Fondation Lejeune ils sont hyperactifs
sur le net est capable d'organiser comme
il y a 15 jours les manifestations de
600 personnes à Lyon ce que je prends
très au sérieux aujourd'hui c'est vrai
ils n'ont pas ou peu de relais affichées
dans le monde politique mais d'autres
collègues l'ont dit avant moi qui
gouvernera la France dans 5 ans
vous dites que notre PPL importe des
débats des États-Unis mais enfin il n'y
a pas besoin d'aller si loin d'autres
n'ont dit avant moi dans l'Union
européenne Malte la Pologne la Hongrie
est maintenant l'Italie sont dirigés par
des formations politiques hostiles à
l'IVG élue sur ses programmes-là sur le
hostilité à l'IVG quant à la Suède déjà
la nouvelle coalition a indiqué vouloir
mettre un terme à la diplomatie
féministe nous les surveillons avec
beaucoup de vigilance vous affirmez que
le Sénat est attaché aux lois veille et
nevirt
permettez-moi madame la rapporteur de
souligner que votre attachement est
quand même assez minimaliste depuis 75
elle loiveille a été modifiée cette fois
vous l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé comme un
acquis collectif vous et vous
prédécesseurs vous y êtes 6 etatiquement
opposé encore il y a 18 mois lorsqu'il
agi de voter la loi Gayot si on vous
avait écouté
l'IVG ne serait si on vous avait écouté
l'IVG ne serait toujours pas remboursé
en 1982 la loi Roudier a été rejetée par
le Sénat les femmes devraient toujours
prouver qu'elles sont réellement des
tresses les mineurs devraient toujours
obtenir l'autorisation de leurs parents
et je ne suis même pas sûr que la pilule
du lendemain serait en vente libre vous
êtes terriblement prévisible
quelle que soit la question dès lors
qu'il s'agit d'améliorer l'accès à l'IVG
la réponse est non
enfin quelques mots sur la phrase
maintes fois entendu qu'il ne faudrait
modifier la Constitution que d'une main
tremblante depuis 2011 le groupe LR au
Sénat a déposé 10 propositions de loi
constitutionnelles votre main ne tremble
pas toujours et sous les présidents
Chirac et Sarkozy il y a eu pas moins de
cinq réforme constitutionnelles
le vote que nous allons émettre tout à
l'heure n'est pas destiné à enrichir les
chroniques de droit constitutionnels
c'est un vote politique que la PPL soit
adoptée ou rejetée le Sénat envers un
signal et ce ne sera pas le même si nous
adoptons d'abord nous sécurisons
davantage à venir et nous enverrons un
message aux femmes et aux progressistes
qui revendiquent affronter l'adversaires
de leur liberté si le Sénat rejette ses
PPL personne ne retiendra vos subtilités
juridiques tous les adversaires des
libertés des femmes tous ceux qui
préfèrent les avortements clandestins
aux droits de choisir cela se sentiront
plus fort parce que moins seul et appuyé
par une puissante institution à la nôtre
et il reviendront car l'IVG est le totem
des réactionnaires des conservateurs des
néo fascistes de tous ceux qui
s'opposent à l'émancipation des femmes
[Applaudissements]
il y a huit jours nous étions là au même
endroit ensemble pour témoigner de notre
solidarité avec les femmes iraniennes et
nous étions unanime
et j'ai dit ce jour-là que nous devions
combattre avec la même détermination
tous les intégrismes et les
totanitarismes religieux tous ceux qui
prétendent que des lois de Dieu sont
supérieures à celles des hommes et il
n'y a pas de différence entre obliger
les femmes à dissimuler leur corps et
leur interdire de choisir quand et avec
qui elles seront mère
qui sont les activistes antivégers
qui sont-ils ces militants qui veulent
empêcher les femmes d'avorter qui
veulent nous renvoyer aux avortements
clandestins si Vitas laissez-les vivre
les survivants et d'autres ce sont tous
des militants intégristes et
traditionnistes chrétiens catholiques ou
évangéliques qui clament leur hostilité
à la liberté des femmes car il n'y a pas
plus de liberté pour les femmes dans les
idéologies religieuses qui leur imposent
le port du foulard islamique que dans
celle qui leur refusent de droit à
l'avortement ou à la contraception voilà
ce que nous voulons faire avec cette PPL
protéger les droits des femmes et dire
clairement à ceux qui refusent des
valeurs de la République que dans la
confrontation avec les intégristes de
tout poil à la fin grâce à nous c'est
toujours la République qui gagne enfin
monsieur le garde sceaux madame la
ministre
je n'aurai qu'un mot bien sûr vos deux
interventions nous ont confortés mais
prenez la main puisque les rédactions ne
sont pas bonnes probablement
déposez-en une mais vous auriez pu aussi
amender madame leur rapporteur bastiné
par art que vous amendiez des PPL de
l'opposition
mais déposer un projet de loi
épargnez-nous ces allers-retours s'il
vote
aléatoire dites que le gouvernement ne
soutient pas simplement le Parlement
mais qu'il le veut que le droit l'IVG
soit constitutionnalisé
[Musique]